[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS:
Understanding variation is
one of the key lenses of
our theory of improvement.
As improvers, we aim to reduce
the variation of process
and create a process that achieves
a certain level of reliability.
One tool that can help us
understand variation is a histogram.
A histogram is a chart
that can help us understand
the distribution of continuous data.
So for example, let's imagine you work
in a federally qualified health center,
and you are tasked to improve the
patient cycle time in a clinic.
The patient's total time from
appointment start time to completion
is important to the patient experience
and important to the clinic's
efficiency.
So using a data collection
form, you collected this data
for the cycle time of
patients in a single day.
So imagine here we've got our minutes
going along the left hand column,
and we've got the number of patients
that had a cycle time within that time
interval on the right hand column.
And so what we're going to do
is draw the actual histogram.
And a histogram looks very
much like a bar chart,
but the bars are organized
by the time interval.
So let's draw our bar chart.
And again, we're working on cycle time.
And along the x-axis we're
going to put in our times here.
So we've got 10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60.
And then I just lumped anything that's
over 60, because for the most part,
we don't want that.
And then on this side, so this
is-- let me put my time here.
It's good to label your axis.
On this side, I'm going to
put my number of patients.
So I'll go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And again, this is the y-axis.
Now I want to label that as
well, so people who can see this
know what it is that we're tracking.
So now I can come along
here with my data,
and we just create-- we go
with each time interval,
and we create a bar that corresponds
with the number of patients.
So for patients that waited only
10 minutes, those lucky few,
we're going to come along,
and we will do 2 patients.
We'll make a bar.
Let's just color it in, so it's
a little bit easier to look at.
Great.
So now as you look at
your cycle time data,
you can look for the
number of patients that
had cycle times in each of
the various time intervals.
Once you've plugged in all the data,
you'll see the distribution of the data
and better understand the variation
that exists within your process.
So two things to look for at the
start is, does this histogram
show a distribution that
appears symmetrical?
So if you look at this
chart, for example,
it looks kind of like a mountain.
So it's pretty symmetrical.
Now, it doesn't mean that you
like the variation that exists,
and the times that are here, or that
you're happy with the amount of time.
But this kind of shows that you've got a
process that doesn't have any outliers.
And now you can work on trying to
figure out how to reduce the variation
and reduce the time to
whatever's appropriate for what
you're trying to improve.
Now in some cases, you might encounter
an example where, for example,
here we came along, and let's imagine
this one's just off the charts.
And it's actually 10, or
12, minutes, or even higher.
And you notice that this particular
interval has an outlier or something
that just jumps out at you.
And it says there's something
else going on here that's
an area that we need to figure out.
And so that can be a
helpful thing to point out
when you're looking at
your histogram to identify
if there are some special places that
may be in a certain time interval
or after a certain point.
There's something unusual that's
outside the symmetry of the process.